بلدته بهروديشنا وقد اصبحت اثرا بعد عين
دمرت معظم ومبانيها وهجرها اغلب اهلها بعد
ان طالها قصف عشوائي على مدى اشهر من حرب
ضروس اتت على الاخضر واليابس حيث لا حصانه
لاي مبنى
هي واحده من عده بلدات وقرن مما صارت تعرف
محليا بقرى الاشباح ومثلها قريه دوفنجه
الطرق المؤديه اليها لا اثر للسكان هنا
وحده مشهد الدمار ذاته يتكرر في كل القرى
التي زرناها
التقينا بدميري
عن ما تبقى من سكان هذه الكره ليقدم لهم
شيئا من الطعام الساخن الذي اعده مع
اصدقاء
مدمره تماما ومن الصعب جدا العثور على احد
هنا لكننا لن نستسلم
في قريه اخرى التقينا بفيتاري الذي صادفا
ان احضر بعض العمال لاصلاح سقف منزله
المدمر قبل بدء فصل الشتاء تحررت قريته
كما يقول لكن بالرغم من ذلك سيصعب عليه
العوده للاستقرار فيها
هذا صاروخ من مروحيه اصاب الاشجار هنا
بعدها غادر والدي ثم ازدادت حده القصف
كثيرا وهربت قبل ان يسيطر الروس على
القريه لقد دمروا كل شيء
ليست دمار وحده وانعدام الخدمات الاساسيه
ما يمنع الناس من العوده الى هذه الكره بل
ايضا مكلفات المعارك الضاريه التي شهدتها
المنطقه
فهذه القرى تقع الى الشمال والشمالي
الغربي من مدينه سلوفيانس الاستراتيجيه
وهي اما قربها او على ضفاف في نهر 06 الذي
كان يشكل الحد الفاصل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه التي كانت
السيطره على سلوفيانس احد اهم اهدافها قبل
ان تسحب شرقا بعد الهجوم العسكريه
الاوكراني المعاكس
قرى صغيره لا تحمل كثيرا من الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه غير ان الجغرافيا وضعتها في
طريق الاهداف الكبيره
للفريقين المتحاربين مشهد مرشح للتكرار
مرات عديده في حرب لم تكتب اخر فصولها بعد
الجزيره وقطعت دونتس